hello that Gao the glass is here and I
am going to review Turtles forever the
first crossover between the 1980s Ninja
Turtle cartoon and the present-day Ninja
Turtles cartoon now one of the things
you might be wondering is how come I'm
not reviewing this as the nostalgia
critic well when I was trying to find
the proper movie to review for the
hundredth episode it came down to two
choices one of them you'll see in
hundredth episode and the other was
turtles forever everyone's been asking
me to review it since the date was
mentioned I get emails up the wazoo
about this special and the reason I'm
not doing this review is the nostalgia
critic is because Turtles forever is
well really really good I've never
watched the new Ninja Turtles cartoon
but you don't really have to if you're a
fan of the original or even anything
Ninja Turtles related you're probably
really gonna love this the way the
characters interact off each other and
the constant confusions of how the
worlds work is unbelievably clever
everything that made the original
cartoon great as well as extremely goofy
is acknowledged and celebrated here and
I'm sure even though I never really
watched it everything that made the new
cartoon really good is also here as well
the attention to detail it's remarkable
the old animation right down to the
backgrounds looks identical to the
original show and to be honest it's very
surreal but in a good way
it's actually really cool to see the
characters drawn like this again and to
see them interact with today's animation
is really neat every joke you'd expect
is thrown in there but they also make
references to jokes you never would have
thought of and some of them you really
have to know the turtles history in
order to even get it's obvious the
writers worked really hard on this and
we're not just trying to make a silly
commercial crossover but a legit story
for the fans of both TV shows on top of
that it isn't just comprised of nothing
but jokes it actually has a very well
thought-out story and sort of keeps you
guessing in what direction is going to
go in next
it takes itself seriously but not too
seriously it's just the right amount of
jokes in action goofiness and story now
if I do have any problems with it I'd
say that's in two minor areas one is the
voice acting and don't get me wrong it's
not bad but it's not the original cast
from what I can tell none of the
original voices were brought in from the
1980s show not even Uncle Phil as the
shredder and that
really pisses me off because
that was the funniest character to me
all of them had great comedic timing it
really sucks that they're not here I'm
not really sure why they didn't get them
but it is a little distracting the voice
actors they did get try their best to
imitate them and to be honest April and
the owner Raphael's voice are almost
identical but I still wish they got the
originals it just doesn't seem right
without the real people the other thing
that annoys me is that the turtles from
the new cartoon keeps seeing what the
shell I mean not just a couple of times
I mean like over and over and over again
I know it's nitpicking and all but they
say it like every other second and it
gets really old really fast it's ironic
that they make fun of the old Turtles
for their lame puns when all the new
turtles seem to have is this one stupid
line I mean come on guys can't you do
variations on it at least well like I
said this is nitpicking it doesn't even
come close to ruining what really is a
well thought out special it has a good
story all the identities match up and it
doesn't seem forced it seems really
natural how these characters interact
off each other like I love how the old
whiny shredder constantly keeps bugging
the newer darker shredder or how the old
Turtles shout how they had to save April
even though they have no idea where she
is or what she's doing they just know
they have to save her the contrast
between the two worlds is just great and
the constant twists and turns the story
keeps throwing it you are extremely
clever if you're not a Turtles fan you
won't like it but why the hell would you
be watching it anyway if you're not if
you are a turtle's fan this is one hell
of a great special in fact if it turned
out this was the last thing ever made
based off of the Ninja Turtles I'd be
satisfied honestly it'd be a good place
to end it it seems like everything has
come full circle whether or not it
doesn't here we'll have to see but
either way it's a really smart clever
well-thought-out special that these
people obviously put a lot of time into
as of now I don't think it's on DVD but
you can probably find it on YouTube
that's where I found it trust me when I
say it's a must-see for any Ninja
Turtles fan well you're all wondering
what I thought and that's my two cents
here Turtles fan go see it you won't be
disappointed
you